en qué puntos se quedaron las
negociaciones durante el mandato de
santos y se podrán retomar ahora desde
ese punto en concreto
lo fundamental es entender todos grandes
logros comentó esa mesa fue una pese al
fuego bilateral que se mantuvo durante
102 días y que le mostró la voluntad de
ambas partes por avanzar hacia la paz y
sobre todo lo que eso produjo de
bienestar en las comunidades y dos un
ejercicio que se hizo de
y participación de la sociedad que en
las afueras de bogotá en tocancipá donde
se empezó a diseñar un modelo de
negociación con participación de la
sociedad está algo en el que le viene
siempre insistido yo creo que parte de
lo que hay que hacer ahora es evaluar
esos 5-10 años de negociación para saber
lo bueno lo malo y lo feo y a partir de
ahí teniendo en cuenta que una nueva
coyuntura replantear la negociación pero
de ninguna manera dejando a la basura
todo lo que ya te había caminado usted
se ha señalado además varios errores en
los que no se puede caer en esta
negociación entre ellos pensar que por
haber un gobierno de izquierdas la
negociación está casi hecha como
negociar entonces con una estructura
horizontal donde hay muchas columnas
independientes a los mandos y además
como negociar desde una supuesta
afinidad ideológica
uno de los grandes mitos que se maneja
que deben estar dividido no debe
mencionar concepción asamblearia de su
organización y esto le plantea estar
haciendo consultas por eso mientras las
par negociaban de una manera directa por
ti los comandantes estaban allí la
delegación de diálogos del pasto de cdn
tienen que venir a colombia para hacer
cultas pero eso no significa de ninguna
manera que sentir lo que yo sí veo es
que hay una voluntad demostrada y esto
está en que cada vez que él llama oa una
paro armado o a una tregua bilateral
todas las estructuras obedece por tanto
en yo sí creo que hay una voluntad y un
acuerdo al que se puede llegar sin
embargo como sabemos en todo proceso de
paz prácticamente hay disidencias tropas
de gustar que la distinción sean tan
pequeñas como sea posible y ha escrito
usted también sobre no centrarse
únicamente en la entrega de las armas y
aprovechar para avanzar en la solución
de las raíces del conflicto que
exigencias históricas ha tenido lln y
que podría ofrecer el gobierno de petro
no sólo a la guerrilla sino al conjunto
del país
sin duda yo creo que uno de los graves
problemas que es creer que la única
solución al conflicto armado de la
entrega de las armas no porque sabemos
perfectamente por la experiencia que
tenemos es que comprar mil fusiles en el
mercado ilegal se consiguen en un mes o
dos meses ese no es el problema el
problema fundamentalmente es atender las
causas en el caso de las partes miro
mucho a las consecuencias de la guerra
los crímenes de la guerra de guerra a
través de la gp o la congestión de la
verdad pero se descuidaron los problemas
destructivos sobre esto tanto
historiadores de derecha como de
izquierda han coincidido es decir que
estas razones del conflicto que deben
ser atendidas para cerrar el pico de la
mejor manera